all right so this is blumhouse doing
their blumhouse thing which is take a
story that wasn't horror
but might lend itself to horror and then
make a horror-ish
version of that story i mean good on
them all things considered that's not a
bad market to corner it's a pretty good
idea
[Music]
freaky so freaky is directed by
christopher landon who's the director of
happy death day
and the premise is so it's freaky friday
and the movie's coming out on friday the
13th
friday the 13th i guess i mean thursday
the 12th
point is the premise is kind of like
freaky friday but with a serial killer
and a high school student vince vaughn's
big serial killer jason voorhees-ish
dude
and then he swaps places with this girl
who's a high school student so now
vince vaughn's serial killer guy's mind
is in the high school girl's body and
vice versa her mind is in his body so
the mind of the girl in the big vince
vaughn serial killer body needs to
convince her friends that she's actually
her inside this big serial killer body
and they need to reverse this and really
when this movie
started i was hooked this movie has an
amazing hook
it's just these four high school
students in this house
and then vince vaughn jason voorhees
style starts dispatching them
but the kills were really well executed
but then after that
the tone of the movie changes it's no
longer
that it's no longer serial killer bloody
fashion horror movie freaky friday
style really it's a dark comedy
adventure they're going around this town
trying to figure out how to reverse this
all the while trying to avoid the cops
one of the cops being a family member
you know so it gets a little complicated
and at that point
it felt like the movie dragged on a
little bit nothing the movie doesn't
have enjoyment i thought vince vaughn
was good i mean he's not jack black from
jumanji welcome to the jungle good
i will try not to compare everyone who's
in a movie with this premise with jack
black from welcome to the jungle but
i personally thought he was great in
that movie but you know vince vaughn was
good another thing i really liked were
the supporting
the friends i was gonna call them the
supporting friends
they're very supportive friends but i
thought they were really good it could
have just been the vince vaughn show the
entire time but i thought the friends
and vince vaughn i thought they all had
chemistry together and the friends stood
out it doesn't change the fact that i
thought
at a point the movie lost a little bit
of momentum
you know like not that the movie's bad
the movie's fine but that's what i have
to say about the movie you know
it's fine you know how that phrase is
i'm not saying like that's a fine film
but you have to do the wave with the
word it's fine
that's where i am with this one it's
kind of a take it or leave it thing i
thought the movie was it was fine
there's a part of me that i know is a
personal bias because
the intro was so i was so
hooked by it but the movie never
delivered more of that i got what they
were doing they were doing that cabin in
the woods thing where it's
kind of commentary on horror movies
doesn't change the fact and this is the
fact of the matter i was never
as entertained with the rest of the
movie as i was with the intro of the
movie i was more interested with the
serial killer in her body
changing up her entire vibe in high
school like her entire persona she's
flipping the script hawk style or
he is flipping the style you get what i
mean i wanted to see more of that this
serial killer could have really done
some damage but
it's only a day you know it's one movie
it's not a very long movie but the movie
feels longer than it is
which is the reason i say it felt like
it was dragging a bit this
premise actually lends itself to being
an
hour-long episode of a series like it's
a buffy the vampire slayer episode i
don't know if buffy the vampire slayer
has or has not done it because
i don't know all the episodes of buffy
the vampire slayer but if they haven't
done this
consider me surprised if not shocked it
seems like something that
must have happened in buffy the vampire
slayer i mean i could see this movie
being one of those movies that
picks up steam and becomes some weird
cult classic but
it's not that to me not yet i don't
think it will be i like vince vaughn i
like the friends i like the chemistry
among all of them but a serial killer
being in a high school student's body
like
it just lends itself to more interesting
premises some of which they did do a lot
of which they didn't which is a weird
way of saying i wanted to see more of
the serial killer doing stuff i don't
know what that says
i don't know what it means i don't know
but like i said what's the word that's
right
the movie's fine it'd probably be better
if i were drunk
yeah now it's a party i get you have to
call it freaky because you can't call it
freaky friday
and you can't call it friday you can't
call it friday the 13th
but can you call it freaky friday the
13th all right so freaky have you seen
it why did you think about it is this
the movie
it's it's not on streaming services i
guess this is the movie that's like all
right
if you haven't gone out to the movie
theaters yet this is the one
is this the movie that's gonna get you
out there are you gonna you know
wait wait for 2021 so the movies that
were supposed to come out in 2020
that were postponed to 2021 could then
be postponed to
2022. whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you